John - Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday, and here I am in beautiful Florida!
Hank - And here I am in beautiful Florida!
John - What? It's a reunion video!
Hank - It never gets old.
John - It never does get old, I still find this funny.
I don't know if they do. Ah, it is very hot.
Both - Hot hot sand hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot
John - So Hank and I are at a family reunion in seaside Florida.
The world capital of teenagers who don't know who we are.
What's it like? Well, it's been like this basically...
-dramatic music (Mars by Holst)-
John - I got these for Henry but they were too big.
Hank - Hi John.
John - What are you reading?
Hank- Endymion
John - NERD!
Hank - Yeah...
Hank - I did it!
Hank - I killed the piggies!
Killed the piggies.
John - And you got one whole star
John - So Hank, we're here in Northern Florida, and yes I am wearing an inner tube,
that just sticks to my body, because you know my belly is too big.
Hank - You don't need a bigger tube. It's the perfect size
John - It's all the tube you need.
Hank - It's just like the internet
John - How is it just like the internet?
Hank - We just all want bigger tubes!
John - You know in all the thoughts from places videos I try and draw out some tortured metaphor but that's the worst one yet.
Katherine - Let's noodle.
John - Noodle Attack!
John - Do not.
John - Do not shake your hair this close to the camera Justin Bieber.
John - It burns, doesn't it burn?
Hank - It burns
John - It burns!
-dramatic music (Mars by Holst)-
John - Hank, you are the younger brother but your marriage continues to be an inspiration to me.
I'll see you on Friday.